[Music]
say hello to the new iphone 13. like the
previous year we've got the 12 pro pro
max the 13 and 13 mini with increased
battery life performance new displays
colors improved camera systems with
cinematic mode and sensor shift on all
devices and macro mode and 3x telephoto
on the pros with pro res raw video
coming later on it did seem initially
like this was only a small refresh from
the 12s but i was actually quite
surprised to find out this was more of
an upgrade than i originally thought
[Music]
so testing out cameras on the new
iphones is obviously something that i
love so much so we're gonna start by
doing that first so the cameras on both
pros and both 13s are identical so
either one that you choose it's going to
be the same with the iphone 13 pro
you'll have the 3x zoom but on the
iphone 13 there is no zoom on this so
that would be the reason that you would
choose the pro so for the sake of this
we're going to test it out using the
pink iphone 13 and the sierra blue 13
pro max
on the iphone 13 here's the wide angle
and the one x so on the iphone 12 pro
and the 12 pro max there was a camera
difference so you had to choose do you
want the sensor shift technology and the
two and a half times zoom this time you
don't have to choose thank you apple for
making them consistent across the board
let's take some more photos shall we
so one of the things that i'm so
impressed with is macro mode and this is
exclusive to the 13 pros this will
basically just auto switch into macro
mode and you can get about two
centimeters away like look at this color
look at this detail and if you think
that this is something that you could do
before you're absolutely wrong let me
show you so if i try to do this on my 12
yeah that looks great really good
content
very clear crystal clear no
so the fact that we went from this to
this if that's not a reason to upgrade
but this is a pretty big one
i'm super impressed this also works with
video so this is video
look how close i am to that
no
freaking way
[Music]
i'm gonna try to take a picture of my
eye what do we think is it focus it it
actually locks yeah you can go closer
right there keep going closer
go closer really yes
oh my gosh but it's in my eye
great
ew
it's so disgusting ew ew i don't like it
it looks like it's like a tarantula
coming out of my eyelid so this is a 13
which it does not have macro mode so i
just want to show you in case you think
that i'm lying about it no macro mode it
is not focusing
[Music]
[Applause]
all right we have found
we found a bug
next time we're gonna do macro content
remind me not to drink like four cups of
coffee
oh
[Music]
one of the cool things about the new
iphone 13s is there's a new cinematic
mode and this is across all four iphones
so no matter which phone you get this
mode will be enabled and what's really
cool about it is it kind of emulates the
way that filmmakers create videos a lot
of films and movies and music videos and
even my own videos are all shot on
cameras with large sensors with high-end
lenses and these things can get very
very very expensive so what's amazing is
the fact that apple has been able to
kind of integrate all of these
filmmaking techniques and even get this
really cool bokeh look so the real
question that i have though do you think
a is the iphone or do you think b is the
iphone i'll leave it up to you guys
leave it in the comments below and you
can check instagram and twitter for the
answer after this video is posted the
cool thing though about cinematic mode
is you can actually go in post and edit
the aperture so i can go in and decide
if i want more or less bokeh and to be
able to do this on the iphone is pretty
impressive also using ai it will decide
what should be in focus this is a really
cool demo that i did in panera where i
was talking to jake super casually not
planned or scripted at all and watch how
awesome this is it started focusing on
me
as soon as i looked back it focused on
jake and then back to me when i turned
back around
impressive
[Music]
oh i
did not realize there was cinematic
front-facing camera what
cinematic up
no wait oh my i'm freaking out
i've had this phone for way too long at
this point i should have noticed this
this new display looks incredible not
only does it go all the way up to 120
hertz refresh rate but it's also much
brighter and in sunny situations i'm
always outside filming i've already
noticed a huge difference
so i do have both versions of the pro
this is the sierra this is the new
beautiful blue color and this is the
gold the gold actually looks a little
bit different than the previous version
like iridescent kind of gold color on
the back and then obviously around the
edge it's super shiny but these both
look so good
[Applause]
also because we're running ios 15 i
forgot that they have the live text
option watch this oh emergency uh after
hours let me take a picture of that and
i'm going to copy that phone number and
i'm going to call them
ready paste
uh yeah so my emergency is that i'm so
incredibly impressed with the new iphone
13 that i might need some sort of
resuscitation do you guys offer that
kind of a service or what do you guys do
i think a lot of people sometimes forget
that the pro version of the iphone has
the ability to shoot raw photos this is
actually incredible because you're able
to shoot photos you can edit them
however you like the iphone
automatically already takes really great
photos but sometimes they do have a
little bit more of an over-processed
look so with raw you can make them look
however you want another really cool new
feature that i want to show you guys is
how you can now swipe to customize the
looks on your camera and this is amazing
because if you have a certain look that
you like i love super vivid contrasty
saturation all the way up if you haven't
noticed so with this i can actually set
that as a custom preset and all of the
photos that i take will automatically be
taken like that
[Music]
i've been having so much fun testing out
these phones and now it's time to make
my little iphone rig i'm going to be
testing out a couple of different things
but doing this allows me to kind of get
the same shot from the same angle at the
same time so we can really assess what's
going on
for this test i'm going to try the 13
promax against the 12 pro regular and
the difference here is in the 12 pro
this one did not have censorship
technology so i want to kind of see what
the difference is as far as
stabilization and i'll show you guys the
difference in the zoom as well let's
take it to the streets
or sidewalk
oh
no i did not see there
[Music]
okay i want to test out the ultra wide
now the 12 was a fixed focus so the 13
this close up little leaf right there
that's all in focus and you'll see over
here on the 12 even if i tap to try to
focus
it
cannot
like all this stuff is in focus on the
13.
that's impressive
this is video that's also shot on the
mini but also shot on the pro max look
at you cool truck
okay 1x zoom
oh man that 3x
really gets us that detail now let's see
what it looks like if we do a digital
zoom
all the way into 3x on the mini
so you'll be able to really see the
difference of optical versus digital
zoom here let's zoom in even more on
that 13 pro max that's 9x digital versus
3x digital on the mini
should we get some ice cream probably i
have apple pay hooked up now so i wonder
what else i can buy with apple pay so
the new wallet actually has find my
integration and this is pretty much very
similar to the previous version it looks
the same feels the same except for this
i haven't set it up yet so you guys are
witnessing this for the first time
there's my wallet it is connected to the
back of my phone and when i unlock i can
add it in so it'll be able to find my
wallet which is really convenient since
my last wallet got stolen
this is cool let's see if i lose it if
i'll be able to find it i'm to go give
my wallet to this nice gentleman over
here could you hold my wallet
sure just just i'm going to come back
for it i'm going to find it okay and act
like it was missing
do you want some ice cream oh no my kids
are there okay the thing is i just ate
lunch and i don't really want ice cream
so maybe i can
buy somebody else's ice cream look i
just got a notification that said
justine's wallet was detached my wallet
was left near here
look at that there it is it just got
drizzled
it's so cool
can i buy their ice cream for them get
whatever you want oh my god i'm so happy
i got to buy her ice cream
okay here you go now i gotta go find my
wallet that i gave this man over here
yes
back on
cool wallet test complete you know what
else we can do cinematic vertical
it's a thing
i think the best thing about cinematic
is being able to adjust the aperture
afterwards this is giving an all-new
meeting to fix it in post which i hate
to say and i also hate to hear it
[Music]
i can't believe how impressed i am with
this macro mode like it's honestly so
incredible the other thing that i've
noticed is it does feel like with hdr4
the colors and everything are so much
more vibrant i'm able to really be
backlit the iphone 13 is making me so
i've tried to angelic you this a hundred
times
[Music]
you don't change
when do i have to go
how much time do i have now
shoot
i think i got the shot
[Music]
it really
is something
[Music]
setting up for time lapse so i'm going
to do a time lapse with the 13 and the
13 pro maps
thank you guys so much for watching i
hope you guys enjoyed this video i had
the best time ever of course as always
reviewing these phones there will be
more videos to come so make sure you
subscribe hit the bell to be notified
when i post a new video and be sure to
leave me some comments below if you guys
have any questions or anything that you
would like to see me test out in the
next video and now cue the sunset time
lapse
[Music]
tranquility
is anybody
[Music]
you